have you ever seen something you weren't
supposed to
something that made you feel off
something you regret
secrets like these are best kept to
yourself but since you're still alive
whatever you saw wasn't nearly as bad as
what peter holland saw one
fateful night in january of 2015.
peter was an unremarkable man an office
worker
slaving away at the daily grind and like
a lot of people
peter enjoyed nothing more than coming
home after a long
hard day kicking back and watching some
tv
it was this innocent activity that led
to peter's horrifying brush with
scp-5049
altering the course of his otherwise
average life
forever the event started at around 10
05
pm peter was channel surfing glued to
the couch in his sparsely furnished
apartment
commercials commercials commercials as
far as peter's tired
eyes could see he paused for a moment to
watch the end of an ad for a car
he could never hope to afford on his
salary but something stopped him from
changing the channel again
the next ad had begun and it was playing
a strange
scratchy jingle that gave peter an odd
sense of unease
but even stranger than that was the text
on screen
demon dan's discount homunculus depot
in baby blue bubble lettering he forced
a smile
this had to be some weird comedy skit or
viral marketing campaign or maybe it was
something he drank
but no this was a real commercial
and things were about to get even
weirder
the peppy logo faded to a concerning
sight
a tall humanoid figure dressed like a
used car
salesman but one that definitely wasn't
human
his skin was dark green and covered in
patches of
thick fur he had long fingers with
intimidating claws and a grin
full of needle-like [ __ ] it looked
almost demonic and after a few seconds
the demon began to speak
hey there folks it's your man demon dan
coming at you with the latest and
greatest deals from demon dan's discount
homunculus depot
we've just accepted a shipment of brand
new models that would make even the most
discerning customers weep with
excitement
let's see what we've got the creature
apparently named demon dan stepped away
from his desk
revealing two long furry goat legs that
ended in large pointed hooves
peter now assumed he really was going
crazy
but at this point he was along for the
ride demon dan continued
his pitch looking to make your way
through the capitalist hellscape that
makes home look cozy
come try one of our newest businessman
models
dan gestured behind him to where peter
was horrified to see a total of 52 adult
male human bodies
hanging from a wall there was something
uncanny about them
they seemed almost hollow like a highly
realistic costume or a prop from a
horror movie
peter didn't have much time to think
about it though as demon dan went on if
you're looking for an extra challenge of
inequality the businesswoman model may
be a right fit for you
the commercial then reveal the wall of
human female bodies strung up
in a similar fashion now you may be
thinking
but dan business sounds hard i just want
to have some fun
and the fine team here at demon dance
discount homunculus depot have got you
covered
the camera zoomed out to show an area of
the store filled with children's
decorations
and more of these strange hollowed out
human suits in child sizes to match
and who has more fun than kids no one
that's who for a limited time the
purchase of any child size unit comes
with a complimentary 50
off coupon for parental units you just
can't say no to a deal like that
before peter could process the madness
that was unfolding before him
the camera cut again the store's logo
appeared on the screen once more
along with several cuts to locations
around the store itself
there were more human bodies hundreds of
them
demon dan's sleazy voice rang out over
all of it
here at demon dance discount homunculus
depot we know it's not all fun and games
the bravest among us have a mission to
accomplish the seven lords are ever
planning their invasion after all so
you're looking for function over form
well we've got that in spades down here
in the tactical services department
you'll be kicking ass in no time when
you're wearing the latest models at the
best prices
seven lords invasion what did any of
this mean
suddenly the camera was showing him a
new room red curtains parted revealing
more of these person suits
several bearing a striking resemblance
to real human
celebrities he managed to make out gucci
mane
avril lavigne paul mccartney and britney
spears before demon dan's appearance
once again drew his attention
i've got a special treat for you we're
happy to announce the vip
look-alike department we all know how
difficult the creation of homunculus is
it's a fine art that takes years of
practice so when a replacement order on
vips comes in
every detail needs to be perfect
unfortunately that's not always the case
but for the right price you too can look
like famous icons from around the globe
the image of celebrity bodies faded from
view
and peter was left looking at the
grinning demon dance standing behind the
front desk of his impossible store once
more
he said there you have it folks come on
down to demon dance discount homunculus
depot
if you're viewing the advertisement then
you've been selected for entry please
enter the nearest door for instant deals
and upgrade those old duds for one of
our newest models
what are you waiting for come on down
the logo popped up again
hovering above some bold text that said
please enter the nearest door
peter had had enough he switched off the
tv what a horror show
he thought they should just warn you
before they put short horror films on tv
like that he had no idea they could just
slip them in among regular commercials
surely demon dan in his store couldn't
be real right
but as his eyes drifted to the door in
his room he didn't feel quite so
certain well there was only one way to
find out
peter got up went over to the door took
a deep breath
and walked through it peter holland was
never seen again
not as himself anyway the scp foundation
has long been aware of this sinister
transmission known as scp-5049-2
and luckily has found ways to prevent it
from claiming more victims
the foundation television analysis
department as well as web crawler 40y40
which is the software the foundation
uses to root out anomalous activity
online
are always vigilant for signs of demon
dan's commercial running
just observing demon dan who is himself
classified as
scp-5049-a and his ads put you in
immediate danger
as they can transform any nearby doors
into scp-5049-1s
those are inter-dimensional portals that
remain active for around 15 minutes
after viewing the ad
so then what specifically is scp-5049
it's the entire pocket dimension known
as demon dan's discount homunculus depot
a kettier class spatial anomaly
constantly on the lookout for
new human victims which it transforms
into fleshy suits for its demonic
clients
which let them blend in around humans
prior to its discovery by the foundation
it's likely that demon dan and his
associates claimed hundreds if not
thousands of lives but sadly even
discovering this anomaly came at a
gruesome cost
to the foundation on february 16 2020
the ad played on safe storage warehouse
13's break room
television at the time of the broadcast
four foundation personnel were present
including security agent william birkin
worrying that this was a potential
security threat
agent birkin investigated the door to a
nearby closet
the second he opened it he was
transformed to the storefront of demon
dan's discount homunculus depot
he saw demon dan himself standing at the
corner while
four smaller reptilian imps fought over
a small
flesh suit demon dan scolded them before
turning his attention to agent perkin
just tis you aren't supposed to be here
little man how
naughty i'm gonna have to have a word
with marketing
once i'm through with you agent burkin
fearing for his safety drew his weapon
and
shot demon dan three times the creature
dematerialized
before appearing right next to agent
birkin and disarming him with a swift
chop
the unfortunate security agent was then
grabbed by the considerably larger demon
dan and thrown over dan's shoulder
we know all of this because agent
burkin's standard issue
foundation body camera recorded the
whole terrifying ordeal
even as demon dan dragged the helpless
birkin back into the twisted workshop
behind the store
there birkin saw what would soon be his
own fate
right before his eyes dan's minions
converting human bodies into fleshy
suits for their demon clientele
and this unfortunate security officer
was
next dan gave him over to a pair of
large sheep-like demons
and told them to drain skin and declaw
him
birkin's video feed finally cut as the
demons pulled out their rusty tools and
began to work on him
of course the scp foundation wouldn't
take an attack on one of their
operatives
inside one of their facilities no less
lying down
the unfortunate death of william birken
allowed the foundation to refine their
methods of intercepting the broadcast of
demon dance commercials
they even had a new mobile task force
mobile strike force kappa
11 or the baphomet bashers specifically
to deal with demon dan
and his cronies they did more than just
prevent him from taking new humans
though
when the baphomet bashers teamed up with
an a-class clairvoyant entity to improve
their efficiency in predicting future
broadcasts
they were able to launch sting
operations and arrest 21 different
demonic customers for interrogation
this impressive strike back finally gave
the foundation some meaningful leverage
over demon dan
and through the use of their clairvoyant
entity they were able to call a
temporary truce and arrange a meeting
with demon dan himself captain steiner
an agent of the foundation external
negotiation department was the one to
interrogate demon dan
they sat across from each other at a
table and demon dan was clearly tense
frustrated with the way the foundation
had been messing with his business
all of their sting operations were
frightening off his customers
in return for letting him continue his
work the foundation wanted dan to turn
over all the information on his bosses
and customers
allowing the foundation to track their
movements when dan was evasive about
whether he'd comply
they tried threatening him dan laughed
them off go ahead take your best shot
little man
there's a dozen more just like me you
won't stop
anything finally he was pressured into
giving a yes or no answer as to whether
he'd willingly collaborate with the
foundation
and act as an informant against his kind
when demon dan hinted that he may be
willing to comply
he began to make a horrifying gurgling
noise
and gripped his head in pain he began
speaking in latin in a voice that wasn't
his own
as though the seven demon lords he
served were speaking through him
they said you are a fool jailor
to think a pathetic morsel such as this
could aid you against us
i have allowed you to toil in your own
delusions for far
too long you may have taken advantage of
azimotius all those years ago
but you stop nothing you hinder
nothing you jail and barter to no avail
your time is coming and then
demon dan's head exploded which
obviously prevented him from giving any
incriminating information on those he
worked for
whoever the demon lords are they're
certainly the secretive type
you may think that this is the end of
demon dance discount homunculus depot
and of scp-5049 but soon
another ad ran it advertised the same
products and services out of the same
store
the only difference was that this time a
different entity
was starring in it now go check out
scp-2662 cthulhu
and scp-4000 taboo for more strange
entities from the files of the scp
foundation